la lettonie à son tour votent
l'indépendance le parlement letton a
adopté tout à l'heure à riga une
déclaration restaurant l'indépendance de
la lettonie
mais cette fois les lettons sont plus
prudents ils assortissent cette
indépendance une période transitoire une
nouvelle république balte qui prend ses
distances avec moscou
gilles rabin georges en scène a riga le
début de leur démonstration il grillait
fascistes fascistes à l'adresse des
indépendantistes mais ils ont vite
abandonné ce slogan à double tranchant
pour réclamer le référendum sur
l'indépendance prévu par la nouvelle
constitution soviétique
ils sont peu nombreux mais ils sont
représentatifs des rapports de force
politique en lettonie interpro
l'organisation pro soviétique peut
aujourd'hui se réclamer d'un bon tiers
des votes pour éviter tout affrontement
les indépendantistes ont appelé à la
rescousse les groupes folkloriques de
riga les militants les plus musclés se
font discrets derrière des petites
filles
je passe à face va durer plusieurs
heures sans incident la constitution de
1922 rétabli l'annexion des pays baltes
par staline en 1940 les déportations
qualifié de crime contre les voix de
l'humanité la lettonie a été proclamé
aujourd'hui libre et indépendant la
lettonie est donc la deuxième république
socialiste à faire sécession en moins de
deux mois et c'est un grand pas de
surface et bly qui va devoir affronter
ce deuxième défi d'une part le monde
entier a pu mesurer en direct de la
place rouge le 1er mai dernier à quel
degré d'impopularité en étaient arrivés
le numéro un soviétique
d'autre part le blocus de la vie toi ni
se révéler être une impasse politique
chaque jour qui passe un peu plus la
licra dit n'a pas piller et